speaking of food how does some japanese
street food sound
rocky is live in summerland hanging out
with the only authentic japanese food
truck in nevada which is based
right here in las vegas they're serving
some special food and
advice hey there rocky
hey jc mercedes what did you order did
did you order some yakisoba
yeah i thought i thought okay so don't
worry i'm gonna make you a fresh batch
okay so come on in
to the brittany you were the co-owner
here
tell us what kind of food you specialize
in and let's start cooking
yeah so we specialize in authentic
japanese street food
sorry um food right yeah street and
festival food
so matsuri means festival so that's what
we're doing trying to bring authentic
festival vibes to vegas not sure means
festival i didn't know that that makes
it fun
let's start cooking because i'm ready i
was watching you earlier yeah
so gloves are there okay i'm going to
grab some over here
oh man okay so gloves on how can people
find you guys
um so we do have some social media um
instagram for one uh it's just matsuri
lv
okay um facebook and then we have
twitter and
um we also have twitch so we just kind
of do a little bit of everything
all right i'm touching we're live
streaming right now
they're watching me no pressure okay
first we're gonna get oil so this yellow
one here
okay and we're right in the middle of
the grill but tell us about this dish
yakisoba is an authentic like uh fried
noodle dish
can find it everywhere in japan so under
here you're going to get oh that's right
oh no we've got here we've only got a
few seconds i don't know
we're going to help you so we're going
to throw some veggies
okay go ahead and grab some noodles a
handful of noodles shoot
guys this is like putting you like a
real yeah yeah yeah
the real authentic food truck advice
right now okay you gotta go fast
yeah people want food you gotta hang it
with the water okay
here's your tongs hit all with the water
like just go crazy go crazy go crazy go
crazy go crazy
i love it and you know this this food
truck has been through a lot since the
pandemic hit and i just want everybody
to know they are out here you have
reopened
yeah you're on the road in las vegas
right yes ma'am we're here in vegas um
we mostly stay up in summerlin and down
at the pinball hall of fame
all right you guys have to check them
out i'm gonna get cooking and after this
check's over
looks good thank you rocky we will check
back in with you during the 4 pm
newscast